[Music]
you seem to me like here's someone who's
fearless like if you're shooting a
comedic scene I almost I think that
you're one of those people that would do
almost anything to get the laugh have
you ever said if in situations we've
said nope I'm not gonna do that
yes I'm Aubrey Plaza yes I'll go to the
wall for most things but no not this I
no I don't think so I think you know I
don't do things you know based on what I
would do I in my mind it's what the
character would do and if the character
would do it I'll do it whatever it is
but with this movie there was one well
there was one thing that I ended up
having to do but I didn't want to do it
but the studio basically called us in
the middle of the shoot and said you
know what we're gonna end this movie and
a musical number which is like fine but
I'm not you know there's Zac Efron who's
a musical guy and Anna Kendrick and Adam
Devine her both in those pitch perfect
movies they're all built for that they
know how to I was the one that was like
but I don't know how to do that dance
and sing and they were kind of like well
that's what was gonna happen we're gonna
end it like that and on Saturdays you
have to come to rehearse and you have to
sing and they really like put me through
it and I couldn't say no to that because
they forced me to do it which is fine
but they like you know they they
actually made me do singing lessons like
they had a singing lady there who was
making me do like ah like in front of
the director and I was crying like it
was it not and it wasn't even your
birthday yeah
like it sleeping yeah and that was weird
because I you know I've never been
forced to like record a song and dance
before I felt very like oh well I guess
this is show biz yeah so you you can't
dance at all have you ever I mean did
you tried have you tried to dance in the
past and get any training and dance well
the funny thing is on Saturdays they
made us show up to these rehearsals with
this choreographer who was like a
world-renowned choreographer and you
know everyone like on ik Kendrick and a
Kendrick showed up and she knew what she
was doing and she had the right clothes
on and everything and I showed up in
like jean shorts and like you know
whatever like I didn't like eating chips
like I didn't know like what to do and
then and then she asked me that same
question while we were rehearsing
because I was always asking her like hey
like what do you do with your arms like
when you're doing the moves with your
feet and she was like what are you
talking about she was like I'm dancing
and I was like but what do you do with
your arms and then she was like having
you ever danced before and I was like
you know what I just remembered that
when I was a kid I competed in Irish
dancing competitions Riverdance
which is something that Irish dancing
where your legs go straight out yes and
your arms just stay at yourself yes
which is like which was a very like it
was an existential moment I had where I
realized like oh that's probably why I'm
so awkward and weird is because I was
taught at a young age to have no
expression and not the Irish have the
worst dance and I'm gonna get complaints
from about this now but being a hundred
percent Irish I can say we have the
worst dancing because I'm just straight
by our side or theirs shooting out in
front of us and our faces are just
supposed to be like this the whole time
while we're bouncing up and down with no
joy I know it was I know and I told her
that and she was like oh my god your
entire life makes sense to me now and
she couldn't believe it and I was like
yeah I forget that I was an Irish
dancing competitor but right you forget
things
you